i'm ryan right and i'm gerry and i'm
michelle q welcome to reasons the seat
when we give you reasons to see and not
to see warm bodies yeah party let's hang
out Ryan's consensus there are a lot of
reasons to see warm bodies there are a
lot of reasons to see warm bodies yeah
the filmer rock my [ __ ] Jerry's
consensus I'm gonna have to go ahead and
say the warm bodies is the reason movies
are made more bodies as the reason
movies are made now I know what you're
gonna say you're gonna say hey Jerry
what did you think you're overreacting a
little bit what no Michelle's consensus
they're entirely through the seat warm
bodies they're strong at this is a warm
bodies yeah I really liked it it was
really sweet movie reason to see number
one or this guy this guy's friggin
awesome you know he's really funny and
he's really really likable the guy has a
challenging job because he has to make a
zombie feel three-dimensional but he
really accomplishes the job takes acting
chops I think to play a character who's
basically brain dead and is slowly
starting to learn how to feel emotions
again and then having to combine that
with acting like a zombie yeah I mean
Nicholas Hoult did a great job I can see
how people might not give him the credit
that he actually deserves just because
he does such a great job with the
subtlety that you might not even notice
how great of a job he's doing until
after you reflect on the movie this
could have easily been bashed by a bad
actor he's a very expressive acting you
know his performance really reminds you
that restraint can take just as much
chops as being super emotive reason to
see number two Julie Teresa Palmer is
pretty [ __ ] cute man she kind of
reminded me of kristen stewart but with
boy marked out a lot of the romantic
impact really does have to be credited
towards the chemistry the performances
of our and julie the chemistry and
romance between them really tickles
your heart it's really sweet and they
bounce off each other very well every
situation she's put in she's really
believable he actually certainly has
range I believe like when she's player
of five man I believe in that terror
yeah you know she takes that a very
outlandish situation and then she makes
it believable in a way that we're
nothing feels stilted at all because of
her performance in warming up to our
that could have been very hard to
swallow and she makes that believable
she really does reason busy number three
the directing and writing if someone
were to tell you they're making a
romantic comedy about a zombie and a
human you might be like what the [ __ ] i
wouldn't i love necrophilia yep
directing and writing managed to pull up
all of it in a very natural and a very
believable way like it'sit's funny at
times it's sweet it's romantic it's
scary it manages to pull up a really
weird balance of tone in a really
natural way yeah it's a really quirky
flick but it does have this perfect
blend of zombie movie and romantic
comedy it's not skewed too far in one
direction it's a great blend nothing
felt really force or let's just throw it
in there and meet to make it look cool I
mean the movies foundation is in its
characters and all the main characters
are written with a lot of dimension it's
just such a fascinating take to see it
from a zombies point of view instead it
actually made it a rather unique journey
like I said before this movie is a would
have been really easy to screw up in a
lot of different departments but I just
seemed like Jonathan Levine had a really
distinct vision and he knew exactly what
he wanted to do know throughout this
movie I just had a huge smile on my face
it was so sweet and entertaining
just really captured my heart when the
characters are in jeopardy like those
moments really work for me to like it
got my heart racing a few times bottom
line this director had a lot of tones to
jumble with here yet there's a perfect
blend not too much of anything not too
little of anything and I love how
they're telling two stories that collide
they're telling one story about the
zombies and they're telling one story
about the humans I'd also have to say
don't let the pg-13 rating you know
steer you away if you're really into
zombie movies because the story does a
smart job of explaining how these
zombies don't even bleed I won't give it
away of why that's important but it
certainly is an essence to the story you
know it's not a zombie movie that's
about zombie kills so it doesn't even
need to be rated or really it's not like
the pg-13 restricts it from being what
it needs to be as a horror fan you come
to know how you know zombie movie works
you come to know those rules and warm
bodies really brings a cool new take on
zombie rules and it seems to have
thought about them enough and flesh them
out enough to really make this movie and
its universe work really well it's a
treat as a horror fan to get a
completely different take on zombies
reason to see number for the cast Dave
Frank goes back laying dick please not
just a dick I'm gonna traumatize dick I
mean the guy's good at playing a dick
and John Malkovich's really believable
he brings just the right amount of
military douchebag father and
compassionate sympathetic father to the
role I thought rob corddry brought a lot
of humor in the movie the guy is always
funny [ __ ] yeah he got me cracking up if
you time it was the one moment but it's
just like so funny uh Analeigh Tipton
was also a really good and she's cute as
she also helps to sort of balance the
character of Julie out and she also has
one of the funniest moments in the whole
movie reason to see number five the
soundtrack I thought the music choices
were really well thought out each song
choice enhance the emotions of the
scenes even more I love how the music
was a way of how the characters actually
connected it fits the youthful sort of
quality this movie has in it also
without beating you over the head with
top 40 actually really works with the
demographic it's for combination of
those
means and in the music it really does
provide a moving picture plus you can
tell it they really like their their 80s
I felt the music was never random you
know like a lot of movies tend to kind
of all this just follow this in theirs
and to satisfy alike the youth because
oh this is a popular song but they chose
unique songs that really gave them with
the movie like a lot of nice energy and
fights praising to see number six
cinematography yeah just just on a basic
level I mean it just looked at the movie
looks great and then going deeper you
know the cinematography really helps
tell the story and it really complements
the story the way they chose to express
the visuals is really indicative of the
mood and tone of the entire film yeah
because without the right looking tongue
no matter how good the writing is the
execution would not have been as grand
plus two because of the cinematography
it actually made the effects look that
much better the stylistic flourishes
that the cinematography has really helps
to communicate the sort of the new idea
this movie's bringing into a zombie
story it wasn't anything like super
artsy but it really worked for the tone
that the movie makers are trying to
achieve they didn't ever make it look
too dark or too light you know it was
just right and there are some pretty
cool shots of the city which is
something a little essential for a
zombie apocalyptic film reason to see
number seven the production design
there's an even balance of set and
seating in this movie yeah they create a
really cool zombie apocalypse
environment and they balance it really
well with how it is now versus what it
was like before yeah you could really
feel the history of humanity in the
designs it's a movie full of little
details you know I love the makeup
design in this movie because the zombies
were all mostly makeup and some caught a
little bit of prosthetics here and there
but it wasn't like all out cge Gore
Enoch I just really loved it was
tastefully done it was really simple and
yet worked so well for this movie the
makeup they did of our and the other
zombies of their evolution was just so
fantastic I mean they have some gross
moments too yeah
want to give too many moments away but
there is one moment where a zombie is
just peeling his flesh off it's uh it's
pretty nasty and gross reason to see
number eight the effects yeah man the
bony looked scary they were creepy it
made sense the way they decided to
distribute the effects between practical
and cg reasons not to see there really
aren't any reason there yeah I can see
how people might not like this film just
because look it's a romantic comedy
zombie film those are the genres of this
film and so what do you get yet romance
comedy zombie but I think some people
might expect a little bit more but for
me I thought it was tastefully done just
right I just think it was just so
perfect it gave me exactly what I wanted
and it just I guess like it satisfied
the craving I love the [ __ ] out of this
movie I really do like I was I had the
biggest grin on my face the entire time
it's like I really do think this is the
reason movies are made it in a way
because it made me feel just excited and
alive and happy to be there puts you in
a good mood yeah it's like I didn't want
it it's like I kind of hate to see the
cold hands of logic applied to it
because it's just such a lively film and
I just loved the experience of watching
it and just really like moves you just
so purely I feel emotionally you know I
just want to hug yeah you just want to
be like I love you I want to make love
to a zombie well yeah oh I guess
[Music]
subscribe people yeah click Subscribe
Clint this button tell us your reasons
to see or not to see warm bodies yeah
body subscribe or zombies Lee you that's
true we do have control over that we can
do that you don't wanna gate it's a new
YouTube function do you want to die then
subscribe that's not a threat it's a
fact